ça y arriva que
l'italie n'a
jamais il n'aurait cru qu'un jour une
salle comble et coûterait son récit ce
grand jeune homme au regard sage c'est
d'aghmat ouiiii mer ou d'agde il était
au pian dans ce cinéma de rome d'agde
présente aux italiens son dernier
documentaire un hommage aux habitants de
lampedusa petit caillou au sud de
l'italie premiers bouts d'europe sur
lequel il a posé le pied en 2005 vous
savez mon premier objectif c'était
d'essayer de retrouver de la dignité
celle que j'avais perdu lorsque j'ai
débarqué sur cette petite île
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le travail de dagg c'est le film de
sa seconde vie celle qui a débuté lors
de sa fuite comme des milliers d'autres
éthiopien
l'ethiopie est depuis 20 ans une
démocratie du moins en apparence
vingt ans que le même premier ministre
mélès zenawi dirige le pays en 2005 il
est réélu mais les soupçons de fraude
déclenché une vague de protestations
187 manifestants sont tués et près de 20
mille autres emprisonnés
dagg qui étaient dans la rue prend la
route du désert soudanais ses films
raconte son voyage et le business de
l'immigration
les passeurs violeur la mort en chemin
et la honte du clandestin ils dénoncent
la police libyenne qui ont fermé la
complaisance de l'europe à lampedusa il
retrouve les hommes de la police
maritime italienne qui l'ont appréhendé
sur une embarcation de fortune cinq ans
plus tôt
[Musique]
c'est à 21 qui constate des personnels
nom et prénom
unis a encore appuyé aux plus fortes
les factions du possible les portables
tout carcasse quelconque au père noël
portait un casque
depuis quatre ans dax est installé à
rome pour autant il ne s'est pas arrêté
de marcher
ou ivan ici c'est celui qui arrive ici
se sent libre mais il ne sait pas encore
qu'il lui reste pas mal de route
même si tu as eu le courage la force la
détermination quand tu arrives ici si tu
ne trouves pas tout ce que tu a imaginé
de l'europe tut écroule
depuis quelques mois d'avis en coloc
dans un appartement ses documentaires ne
lui rapporte pas grand chose mais il a
un job dans une association d'aidé aux
migrants il refuse que sa relative
réussite servent d'exemple et encore
moins de référence aux éthiopiens
candidats à l'exil c'est son nom moi je
suis dans cette chambre aujourd'hui mais
ça ne reflète absolument pas la vie des
réfugiés de mon pays la vérité c'est que
la majeure partie de mes amis vit
toujours dans le squat dans lequel moi
aussi j'ai débuté ma vie à rome
il n'empêche aujourd'hui d'agde fait ce
qu'il aime et il est écouté
de plus ici il a rencontré l'amour il
sera bientôt papa d'un bambino italo
éthiopiens
les secrets de rome et ses ruelles non
plus de mystère pour d'agde
mais il est un lieu en particulier qui
pourrait rejoindre les yeux fermés
bienvenue chez lili le royaume du
bigoudi mélinite youpi ce salon de
coiffure c'est le coeur de vie des 6000
éthiopien de la capitale ici l'on papote
dans un mélange dammarie que la langue
nationale éthiopienne et d'italien
[Musique]
côté hommes il y à mimi le vieux pote de
dagg
ce genre de tignasse et très difficiles
à coiffer si je fais une erreur je vais
vraiment me faire engueuler
[Musique]
entre deux mises en plis on sert le café
maison la spécialité du pays envié par
tous les italiens côté femmes il y as
lilly quelques milliers de tresses à son
actif et 12 ans de métier
il me semble que les italiens sont plus
chaleureux avec les étrangers à londres
par exemple personne ne te remarque ici
tu as vraiment l'impression d'être dans
ton pays
entre éthiopiens et romain le courant
passe bien même si en général les deux
mondes se côtoient peu ici les
éthiopiens se divise en deux camps il y
a d'un côté ceux qui sont arrivés
légalement pour la plupart partisans du
régime zenawi et de l'autre les réfugiés
politiques comme d'agde et mimi des
opposants au régime arrivés
clandestinement par la mer leur surnom
les titanic
notre gouvernement se targue d'être
démocratique devant l'opinion
internationale ce n'est pas comme ça
dans les faits il n'y a rien rien du
tout démocratique
il
la contacte un ruisseau
il ya quelques mois c'est vrai
résident
message reçu à 5000 km d'addis abeba
capitale de l'ethiopie la politique du
gouvernement zenawi reste une source de
conflits permanents
[Musique]
à rome la voie des titanic les exilés
politiques à trouver refuge à san
lorenzo au quartier historique de la
gauche libertaire
c'est d'ici qu'est mais radio en dehors
ça où on rouge
chaque dimanche pendant 1h30 d'arrossa
devient fréquence ethiopie au micro nous
loue donne des nouvelles du pays en
amérique dans le texte nous loue c'est
la voix de l'opposition éthiopienne en
italie
[Musique]
il dresse la table de jugurtha gris
metal britannique robert
nous a fuis l'ethiopie ya 20 ans le jour
de la session au pouvoir de mélès zenawi
20 ans qu'elle se bat à distance contre
un gouvernement qui ne parvient pas à
endiguer les famines récurrentes
éducation santé niveau de vie l'ethiopie
compte toujours parmi les 20 pays les
plus pauvres de la planète
nous qui sommes hors d'ethiopie nous
devons porter la voix du peuple celle
des
en ethiopie personne n'est libre de
dénoncer les injustices
[Musique]
les éthiopiens de roms forment une
diaspora pauvres et diviser ceux qui
s'en sortent vivre au mieux dans les
quartiers populaires comme celui de
pigneto
le beignet tôt c'est le fief de moule où
elle est présidente de la petite
communauté éthiopienne de rome à peine
60 membres loulou se démène pour que
perdure l'entr'aide éthiopienne est
l'âme du pays le café
coffee pauvreté c'est la variété verte
il est séché il faut le laver et après
on le met sur le feu à trop fort
tout doucement il faut leur tournée il
va devenir vraiment cheap au maroc
[Musique]
la légende raconte que les premiers
grains de café ont poussé en ethiopie
dans la région de cafard aujourd'hui le
pays on est le cinquième producteur
mondial 1 or noir qui est aussi un
pilier de la vie sociale éthiopienne
ce n'est pas tant pour boire le café que
pour discuter entre femmes à la base ce
n'est pas pour les hommes
ici en italie on prend le café tous
ensemble
même avec les hommes
pourtant en italie ce café laisse un
goût amer à moules ou et à ses amis le
climat politique est devenue délétère
vis-à-vis des immigrés en 2010
berlusconi et la ligue du nord parti
d'extrême droite ont réussi à imposer
des quotas d'étrangers dans les écoles
pas plus de 30% le pays a même tenté une
expérience celle des classes dites
d'intégration en réalité ont séparé les
enfants étrangers des petits italiens
mes enfants me demandais pourquoi il
était mis de côté et il me disait soit
tu nous ramène au pays soit envahie
heures on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
résultat ces enfants sont partis faire
leurs études au canada
cette loi m'a posé un problème mais
sinon les relations avec les italiens
c'est aussi fort qu avec papa et maman
on va parler
les éthiopiens de rome évolue dans une
italie à deux visages l'un solidaire
l'autre méfiant parfois hostile
l'italie est une jeune terre
d'émigration d'à peine 30 ans
à travers ses documentaires d'agde a
entrepris un grand chantier humaniser
les regards
[Musique]
fin du film celui qui de ces mots est
arrivé couvert de honte en italie est
aujourd'hui applaudi une partie de son
contrat est rempli
sans micro d'attaqué c'est poisson
oublient qu'en france mon rêve serait
d'avoir le même public en ethiopie
et de pouvoir lui raconter ma vie ici en
italie et en europe
ça serait formidable
c'est un rêve mais j'aimerais vraiment
réaliser
babin
[Musique]